I'd like to do it like I'd like to get
jiggy at the land I mean let's ride with
you excuse me
stop the hate appreciate it's gonna find
it here yes it has very fun and we long
win on a bang don't worry about it I'm
not worried I'm not worried what do you
know the Patriots are the Superbowl say
Oh real shocker left go you know who's
not yeah you're Eagles no that's shirt
that's definitely not a Super Bowl I
kind of think there's a little Saints
flare to it oh is that right you're
gonna I look like I could be walking
down the street you're about to start
hating on the side right away I didn't
do anything you brought them up throws
out we were doing one of the four teams
that play we're talking about the Rams
in the page I want it I want to say this
yes to Saints fans right what happened
to you is a travesty I wish that upon no
fan base and this is complete sincerity
that was nonsense and I apologize yeah I
want to just get that out there I get
you that was that was a brutal call I
will say though that the Super Bowl does
feel weird from this aspect
20:18 felt like mahomes breeze Chiefs
Saints the whole year yeah the Rams had
their moments the Patriots always have
their moments right but I felt like it
was all leading towards chief Saints
yeah and I really want to say because we
made it about two people mahomes and
Brees it's all about this well it's just
like I hadn't listened that's the
matchup I wanted to see okay good I get
you there but I also picked the Patriots
and Rams to win those football games
because I said their teams are greater
even though we have this sex appeal
matchup at the quarterback position we
like well then let's say this though
right for real yeah we have loved
Rodgers for a long time yeah you are
someone that appreciates great
quarterback no doubt what we witnessed
this year with Patrick mahomes cannot be
forgotten and to everyone out there
that's saying we have all these years
guaranteed look at Dan Marino none of
this stuff is Gerren nothing we don't
know if mahomes is getting back here we
don't know if Tyree Kills gonna be at
this speed the rest of his career I know
about Travis Kelce what we witnessed
5,000 yards 50 touched it right I just
wanted to give it more love we should
because I fell in love yeah with my
favorite quarterback in the NFL I can't
even believe it is blasphemy get out of
here
Aaron we're good we're gonna get a new
host next year don't worry buddy
but wax poetic about I mean it was a
special especially show Patrick mahomes
in this day and age for what he did I
mean guys like Peyton Manning and Tom
Brady you know 50 touchdown passes they
didn't do that until they were in the
middle of their career he already had a
master's a doctor in the court exactly
right this guy throws for 55,000 yards
50 touchdowns his his first year as a
true starter right and all the teams
they face every week knew that that was
the number-one thing to hit a stop and
he's still delivered week after week
after was amazing he is amazing I told
you guys in like week 10 or 11
hey trips are getting the Super Bowl
you're gonna think it's not happening
it's happening this is like if you took
Tim Duncan and LeBron James like their
streaks like put them together right and
then you added Popovich and then like
been like Roger Federer it's hey it's
and then the Yankees in the 90s we will
never see anything like this again in
the history of the NFL Bill Belichick is
by far the greatest coach in the history
of the sport I don't think that's even
like a point to argue anymore
Tom Brady of course what he's doing the
sustained greatness is amazing but the
big thing I want to say to everybody out
there about the New England Patriots is
this stop the hate appreciate
okay they're not gonna see this very
often this is a rare thing and as much
as we all want to hate the Patriots and
I work for them and I know some of these
guys and I have weeks where I go damn
I'm sick of hearing about him I hope
they lose this week it's still
phenomenal what they do in Tanjung this
is the era of salary cap free agency the
league is supposed to be close and
competitive I know I'm going off because
how amazing real it's real it's supposed
to be close and competitive they made
the rules so we would have different
teams be at the top every year and the
only thing that's been consistent is the
New England Patriots for the whole 21st
century it's been the New England
Patriots and I just I'm I'm amazed by it
yeah it's like two 49er dynasties I mean
that's what it is it's amazing it's
challenging but not today to ask for
advice he did I told him relax but you
want to know what sweater to wear next
week that's what sweatshirt gotta cut
these sleeves
as an ecology wasn't seems and let go is
it in the process of doing this show I
think we've made some special
friendships with players that play right
and I think teo and Chad Johnson are at
the top of the list I mean no doubt
about their our buddy
they like wanted to hang out with us and
we were in LA we were like yeah by the
way they're gonna be in Atlanta I email
Sims enough go at gmail.com if you're
gonna make it there they will be there
but I'm on Twitter yeah and I see Chad
Johnson go I want to do my own show
where we got a wide receiver and I get
to work on it right this is that show we
got Chad Johnson antio and mr. Ridley at
a Georgia right who's gonna be maybe a
first-round pick in the NFL what's mr.
Ridley's first name
Riley almost choked there but yes this
is your big audition T oh no Jose think
yeah show us what you got
but seriously they are gonna show us
what they got it is they're the two guys
that I know through my just knowing
people in football yeah they're ultra
talented yeah it's great touchdown
dances and all that but they are
obsessed with their craft they were
obsessed with route running and NFL
receivers still go work with them to
clean up their game and here's why you
see I got this shirt tucked in right
there nothing to me know what that means
no I don't know what assert tucked in
right that means you learned you know
it's okay you don't want a job if you're
going to shirt tucked in cuz you mean
business right
[Music]
hello I am Chad Johnson I am here with
my good friend and Hall of Fame receiver
Terrell Owens and up-and-coming draft
prospect one of the best receivers in
the nation Riley Ridley
stepping up
[Applause]
what do you feel like your best asset is
as a receiver
right now I'm physical okay I'm physical
more physical to any receiver going into
the draft I'm more physical 2 nd dB
so that's something that you don't have
to work on so now you got a word about
working on the finesse part of the game
so you got T yeah muscle right physical
physical get to you and then you have my
skill set was completely opposite don't
touch me I'd like to do it like I'd like
to get jiggy at the line I mean let's
ride with me go and I need all this
space my coach said wonder he said this
to me because he knew I liked basketball
right and this is what clicked for me he
said you have to treat the defensive
back like you're playing one-on-one you
playing one-on-one and you're trying to
get by me what are you gonna do you
gotta make me move right same thing with
every route pretty much because I'm
trying to score a book I'm trying to get
it I'm here you give you two steps and
get right into this okay so I'm here and
I'm going okay initially when you came
up the ball boom boom
you kind of got wide a little bit right
try to stay a little bit me you so I
like what you come on boom here then
kind of get into him invited you can
invite it but you want and when you hear
you want to accept you want to show that
acceleration like you about to go DB
then you stop my problem was when I used
to get it going to my brakes I use just
saying yeah have these flappers out here
and then I had my coach told I'd be a
drama board you know be a drummer boy
then when I did when I did hit
transition its anything out of my brakes
squeak right we're trying to get you to
become a Salesman before you act with a
Salesman I do a dig route based on an
offer of a comebacks name I call the
Simmons center due to the Gatorade I'm
gonna send him to the Gatorade so just
say come back coming here just say the
ball is in there right the ball is in
there and I got a dead ground so this is
what I'm gonna do don't move I'm again
right here
whoof I'm gonna send him to the Gatorade
load up all of this is right here he's
open no soon as you know that way he'd
go in very seldom on Depot's do you just
blow by dude that ain't happening yeah
yeah anything happen unless you just
beat somebody off the line you just yeah
exactly yeah I mean you got to be
goddamn Tyreke hey listen Randy Randy
Randy had a few crazy yeah Randy you see
the mailbox it's really over that not
not everybody's like that he's
freakishly free kids freakishly fast
right y'all mean to the point he started
coming off flying he already do with
Hannah it's a bunch of receives an NFL
right starting two teams there's number
one on every team right what's the
difference in each number one and the
rest receives on the team if something
about that dude that makes them special
there's something about Odell that makes
him different than the rest of the
Giants receivers learn something about
AV that makes them special
something about Julio right you got to
go on wherever you go when you get there
it gotta be something about Ridley that
makes them special exactly that
separates them from everybody else load
up when it's the way you work whether
it's your hand let's defeat whether it's
your routes mmm where's you being
consistent hey guys I see something what
ain't gonna be a bunch of things it's
one thing about four that makes them
great it's a million boxes yeah you're
not gonna hit me let me hit you whenever
I want
so as a receiver you found whatever that
niche about you that makes you special
It's A Wrap I got a brother in the NFL
but to be able to go through this on
your own you know I'm saying they have
great people around you and willing to
help you miss amazing and Cal really if
you see this I will lock you up know you
even a lot nobody nobody what a year for
somebody in left go we tried something
new went out met a lot of new friends
and we actually made some money but you
know that the Super Bowl is not just
about picking the Rams or the Patriots
there's hundreds of prop bets about
commercials and dogs and the National
anthem so I'm up in the stakes $500 I've
found some my old friends and we're
laying them on the props we are here at
the subway with the Patriots legend
Steve Grogan scratch that IRA my good
friend you're so spoiled with this
Patriots team 18 years incredible I'm
excited about prop bets here's one for
you it's a spicy one will Jim Nantz and
Tony Romo say the phrase Hotlanta
the favorite is no you're going with the
favorite I'm going with the favor I
don't care what the odds they're putting
$500 on no no hot Lanta
we are back locking it up with the
legend Dave Super Bowl prop bet boy it's
a good one it's a good one it's hairy
it's furry and it's lobbers okay they're
doing over-under not for the game over
under five and a half commercials during
the Super Bowl that will have dogs in it
this is a legitimate bet the hell bets
on dogs in the Super Bowl that's
probably I need your help we're
currently betting on dogs the Super Bowl
so over under five and a half
commercials with dogs it's the craziest
thing anyone's ever asked me so I'm
gonna say 'under I'm not feeling the
dogs this year Super Bowl prop vet
Gladys Knight singing the national
anthem over a minute and 46 or under a
minute and 46 he's gotta go over you're
sure yes it takes a little time for them
to good do you have any pipes pipes er
yeah you got any yes the dragon he's the
best legitimately forget the prop bets
forget the other somebody's alley has
been the king the entire time playoffs
not so much alley the mush but we can
flip it and the Super Bowl make all our
money back
Patriots favored by a point and a half
over the Rams in Atlanta in Atlanta
Atlanta I didn't want to go against Tom
last week but I told you if he want mmm
we will going with him in the Superbowl
it didn't matter who was coming
on the other side uh I like him against
the Rams even though they got a tough D
I like Tom Brady to pick them apart an
ally lock absolutely I like it hmm I
would go Patriots to my man it's gonna
find you yes it has very fun every lone
win on a bang don't worry about I'm not
worried I'm not worried I like I like
Tom Brady in the Super Bowl I'm
convincing myself again yeah I need your
insight on another problem okay I found
got you there's apparently prop bets for
all of the CBS anchors are and who
they're gonna pick in the game what kind
of blazer are they gonna wear no oh
because they wear the same blazer every
week one of them is Phil Civ uh-uh
do you know him I do know him okay yes
apparently it's minus 120 Patriot right
- 110 ran that I let's just figure it
out with him now yeah and go make a
billion dollar call call him up figure I
just worry you know you got to worry
about like Jimmy the leg who might come
and break your leg once you find out
your cheat in the system good I got a
guy you know you got a guy yeah Phil
you've got a guy too
the thing I worry about is I feel like
Phil would tell them me the Patriots now
and then suddenly be like sorry I don't
watch some film and now I'm going right
well I mean yeah it's too early in the
week I don't think he would know right
now but I do think I mean early proof
play early I mean Phil Simms he you know
knows Belichick played under him for a
long time in the New York Giants I would
think he'd be favored in the New England
Patriots in fact I think he got to be
crazy not to be favored in the New
England I'm gonna call my bookie right
for Simms peace out homies I am love Co
and here are some bloopers that we
haven't seen so we're going to look dumb
and here they are hello we are a cool
item why am i yelling I'm not gonna yell
this time I didn't want to yell that's
why I went really calm but you're a
Yeller you have a big mouth be out of
left code are you gonna be somebody else
now let's go
we took our act on the road to take on
the 49ers the 909 old amendment one
amendment to mmm Aaron Rodgers Kyle
Shanahan will figure out our amendments
Vikings could have lost that game of the
49ers Green Green Bay - god bless you
and God bless Aaron Rodgers yes that guy
really strong together some winning Sea
it's awesome Wow hey I mean I'm too I
can't remember what exactly I was gonna
say we built your friendship well I mean
Parcells didn't want got him peace bro
matchmaker met to make your make me
match your absurd anyways the pizza I'm
Don Corleone I need to shave I'm five
minutes old that's why they call you mo
that's how you say it
get a little no way negative Ghost Rider
negative Ghost Rider
negative Ghost Rider negative Ghost
Rider the pattern is full negative Ghost
Rider the pattern is full como se yamas
I have s to address two sins a lefke the
players show and they can you feel
better man you were wrong you said
Friday don't touch me
punch Big Ben in the lag deck oven
how would he procure such saltwater
taffy I don't know what the cure means
so you'll have to explain that to me
how did he obtain this saltwater taffy
for cents
peace out homey I am the LEF Keowee man
he's the KOA he'll we're gonna spell his
name on the next episode of sins of left
go the show till then we'll have them in
the back learning how to spell what just
happened okay what's up homies thanks
for watching subscribe to the B our
YouTube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here we
have a lot other videos check them out
and then what time does our show come
out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or be
square
he ruined it it was really close